you ready for some hikara Nakamura
trivia sure all right what's your
favorite hikara Nakamura video I don't
know if I have any specific favorite but
anytime like he starts losing and he's
tilting that's that's the most enjoyable
for me
okay oh
no no all right what month was aakar
Nakamura born in December what's his
birthday
so he cars had his birthday during the
London chess classic a few times I think
Anan is probably born on the
13th
December I'm going to guess 9th wow got
it ding ding ding what country was hiar
Nakamura born in I think hiar was born
in Japan what city of
Japan um oaka okay we're killing it how
many siblings does aaro have uh I know
that aaro has a brother who plays chess
uh I'm going to guess that he has one
more sibling no oh no he only has one
and what's his brother's name Asuka
there you go so there I am there I am
you guys that's my brother of course
what happened first you winning the
Norwegian Chess Championship or hikaro
winning the US Chess Championship well
hukari is 3 years older than I am and I
I know he won the US Championship fairly
young and I did lose the playoff twice
so I'm going to guess that he won it
first that's correct what year did he
win it say probably 2003 or 2004 2003
2004 he had it though in chess.com
databased of games what is hiar
nakamura's favorite first move as white
E4 D4 Knight F3 or
B3
I think he's that's yeah it's very hard
okay it's it's not D4 that's for sure um
I think it has to be either E4 cuz
that's his
main that really is his main move but he
he loves the Knight of three setups and
in Blitz and probably plays them in
bullets I would guess Knight of three is
his main first move it actually is E4
yeah so it was the obvious one well
actually I read it quickly I was reading
it his second best scoring move is
actually D3 not B3 so I was wrong about
that which kind of relates to Knight F3
so his was he the best scoring or yes
his I guess the question is what was his
best scoring move E4 Oh I thought it was
the one he played the most yeah good
blooper by me good blooper okay so I'll
say it again of all the moves that he's
played more than a hundred times what is
his best scoring first move and the
answer is E4 oh yeah but it makes sense
that the best scoring move is E4 cuz he
often plays like E4 uh Knight C3 setups
against weaker players he beat all the
time so okay there you go so that makes
sense figuring out the math on that
before chess.com Hikaru was the highest
rated player on the internet chess club
with two usernames two handles do you
know what those two usernames were it
has to be Smallville and capano Bridge
nailed it bonus if you can name his
username on play chess I'm not sure that
I played Hikaru on play
chess no I'm not going to remember that
Star Wars Star Wars yeah I yeah that's
true I definitely played Star Wars
Hikaru has authored one chess book do
you know the
title uh wait a sec I actually have I
have the book that he's authored it's
about bull chess
um I think it's called like one minute
Checkmate or something yeah wow wow with
uh like Bruce Harper is that yeah you're
nailing it okay what is hiar nakamura's
Peak feay
rating let me
see I think K car peaked at well he was
number two in the world where a lot of
people were pretty high
rated so I think it's got to be well
over
2800s
28 17 oh man you are good you were close
286 point something so that was pretty
good all right which of these events has
AAR Nakamura won five of the speed Chess
Championship the jalter chess festival
and the US Chess
Championship uh I think that's the trick
question I think he's won all of them at
least five times only two did win jalter
five times only four yeah oh it was a
trick question yeah doing our best here
who did it call beat to win his first US
Championship like in the last round uh
yeah 2004 uh some reason the name that
pops up is kaidanov so I'm going to go
with that Yar
I yeah there you go close enough no one
would have known that one I think all
right which TV show has AAR Nakamura
made a cameo appearance
on uh I think Yar made um a cameo on uh
billion that's right CU they could not
get me did which is a True Story by the
way what what is it they got him cuz
they couldn't get me oh really yeah
there you go I love that all right last
question when commentating on the xqc
moist critical match how many moves was
that game over in who was hikaru's co-
commentator and what was Hikaru
nakamura's final thing he said right
before the Checkmate how many moves
uh I mean that's the scotch game right
uh like there was rolling made on
F2 How does it
go
C3 R
C5 yeah probably five moves then I think
that was was that four moves one two
three four five six it was six
moves who was his co-
commentator
uh who was come was that the first pod
first
pams too soon Hikaru that was the
line uh was it you no bz Alexandra okay
yeah last question do you remember the
last thing hikaro
said uh random line he didn't like the
variational approach so I'm not sure
that I like the like the variational
approach approach
your no please
don't it's too
soon it's too soon hearu we didn't even
reach a
climax oh we tried to stump you in the
end but we really didn't do a very good
job I wonder if it car was going to do
as well with Magnus Carls and trivia
that was impressive yeah I feel like I
did okay yeah almost a bit creepy almost
a bit
creepy